[Música]
lo primero que quiero decir es que la
cuarentena nuestra oportunidad y la
pandemia no es una oportunidad son cosas
horribles
la cuarentena la vamos a hacer todo lo
que haga falta pero tiene muchísimas
consecuencias complicadas políticamente
económicamente la pasamos mal
socialmente también extrañamos a
nuestros amigos es todo horrible no hay
nada que hacer al respecto y no hay
porqué pensar que es una oportunidad que
hay que aprovechar y que nos estamos
perdiendo de algo si no aprovechamos y
que es un gran momento para aprender no
son el momento para nada es un momento
horrible dicho eso la vida no se trata
otra cosa que de pasar momentos
horribles y aprender de ellos aprendemos
del dolor de la enfermedad de la guerra
de poder muerte siempre lo hicimos y
vamos a seguir haciendo así que eso
vamos a hacer ahora y lo que yo estuve
pensando en traer es una idea en la que
estuve meditando a partir de un libro
que se llama naturaleza moderna que es
el cinesta derek jarman son los diarios
que se arman llegó en las tardes 80
cuando le diagnostican de hb y entonces
decide volver a su pasión de la infancia
la jardinería pero exámenes un cineasta
que de hecho después
es un montón de películas algunas muy
importantes algunas de sus carreras pero
lo que él decide en línea es que bueno
que va a comprar un terrenito en un
lugar inhóspito y horrible y va a cuidar
un jardín y lo que hay impresionado como
persona que escribe es que para él
cuidar un jardín no era hacer tiempo no
era bueno pasar el rato no como ahora
que pasamos el rato cocinando haciendo
pan o lo que sea
o limpiando y pensamos bueno aunque está
lo único que hacemos es lavar platos no
las únicas tareas que nos permiten son
esas y pensar entonces en el concepto de
trabajo reproductivo que es un trabajo
un contexto que sale del marxismo a
partir de fingers básicamente y que
después tomás especialmente el máximo
feminista para hablar del trabajo
reproductivo no está el trabajo el
trabajo productivo que es el que pone
cosas nuevas en el mundo pues vamos
decir o sea un programa de radio con
clavo no importa y está el trabajo
reproductivo que es el que reproduce las
condiciones para que podamos hacer eso
limpiar cocinar cuidar no básicamente es
que cocinar les a los trabajadores para
que al día siguiente ponía las fábricas
o ese trabajo reproductivo y las
feministas llevamos mucho tiempo ya
argumentando correctamente que el
trabajo reproductivo también es trabajo
pero en general lo que preguntamos lo
que a productos lo que argumentamos es
que el trabajo reproductivo tiene valor
económico porque sirve para hacer el
trabajo productivo porque si los
trabajadores no comen o en la fábrica
ahora porque el borde conserva en ese
valor relativo primero no pensamos en un
valor absoluto e incluso más porque no
hacemos como insular extraer mann y
pensar que esa esa diferencia es el
contraste entre trabajo productivo y
reproductivo es una diferencia más bien
ficticia dada por un lado por por
supuesto el género por la idea de que
hay tareas que son importante estas son
las productivas tradicionalmente
realizadas por los varones y las
reproductivas la tradición la mente
realizada por las mujeres son
importantes y también dado por la
modernidad y por la idea de que el
sujeto que vale es el sujeto que hace
algo original que produce valor en el
mundo y que el sujeto que cuida no
cuidar es algo que no te hace especial
no te has originando que hace artista no
seas empresario no te hace una posición
importante no esos son valores con los
que no tenemos por qué comulgar pensamos
que es al revés e incluso dicen las
tareas de cuidados son las más
importantes y en estos días estamos
viviendo sin publicistas sin escritores
sin un montón de cosas está moviendo sin
powerpoint y el mundo sigue girando pero
el mundo no se envía girando sin comida
y sin cuidados
y sin enfermeras y sin salud lo único
que se nos permite hoy es comer y curar
limpia y sin es un mundo mágico entonces
esas tareas tienen un valor que no es
relativo tiene un valor que es absoluto
y no solamente eso sino que no son algo
mecánico que necesariamente tengamos que
pasar por arriba que ojalá no existiera
que ojalá no pudiera ser así limpiar la
casa cocinar resolver la comida pueden
podemos pensar cosas y las hemos pensado
hace mucho tiempo pero lo que yo pensaba
cuando leía a german es que justamente
de podemos también vivirlas de otra
manera podemos vivirlas como tareas que
tienen una sabiduría como tareas en las
que también estamos involucrados como
seres humanos que no son mecánicos y eso
también tiene que ver con pensar
justamente en esto que el titular a la
naturaleza moderna la modernidad no como
el ser humano separado del mundo natural
que solamente hace lo interesante con la
naturaleza cuando la convierte en otra
cosa sino que la relación de cuidado con
la naturaleza también es algo
interesante
la relación de cuidado con nuestros
cuerpos pensemos con general pensamos
que hay que encargarse del cuerpo y al
gimnasio o hay que cocinar solamente
para estar sano para hacer otras cosas
las cosas que importan pero eso también
es es una forma muy muy extraña de
pensar nuestra relación con otro propio
cuerpo no pensar que nuestra mente es lo
que somos y que el cuerpo no es algo que
hay que sobrellevar
me parece que
esta nueva oportunidad y de hecho por
supuesto yo quiero volver a mi vida no
el mundo no necesita más novelas y yo
quiero escribir novelas igual así es la
vida
no todos vivimos en esta contradicción y
esta vida para el absurdo ahora dado que
el mundo necesita más novelas pensé
bueno porque no en lugar de
obsesionarnos con seguir siendo
productivos en estos días y con hacer
todas las cosas y con todo eso porque no
pensar en conectar con el mundo con el
cuerpo con los cuidados con los demás de
otra manera a partir de esto
por eso de hecho cuando me invitaron a
hacer estos castillos que no porque me
pareció que no tenía la pretensión de la
idea original el mundo no haya sido que
la novela del mundo no necesitó otra
idea pero por eso pensé en en realidad
vamos que escribir leer traer algo que
leí algo que me hizo pensar algo que ya
existía en el mundo lo que ya estaba
cuidado que yo que yo estuve con mis
libros y que quizás le sirve a otras
personas no más que escribir leer y más
que hacer cuidar
[Aplausos]